PROSECUTORS AND A POLITICIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE
BUT THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGL
ANGLE.
A LOT OF US GREW UP TO HAVE A
ROMANTICIZED VIEW OF FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY WERE ALL LIKE ELIOT NESS IN
THE UNTOUCHABLES.
TRUTH, JUSTICE AND THE AMERICAN
WAY.
IT WAS ABOUT LOCKING UP THE BAD
GUYS AND PROTECTING THE REST OF
US.
AND, THERE ARE MANY DEDICATED
MEN AND WOMEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SERVING AS ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEY WHO ARE DOING JUST THAT
ATTORNEY WHO ARE DOING JUST THA
THAT.
BUT SADLY, WE HAVE ALSO SEEN IN
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES IN RECENT
YEARS OF PROSECUTIONS OF
PROMINENT FIGURES THAT SEEM TO
HAVE BEEN POLITICALLY MOTIVATED.
PROSECUTIONS THAT RESULTED IN
HUGE MISCARRIAGES OF JUSTICE.
ONE SUCH CASE WAS THAT OF
CONSERVATIVE FILMMAKER, AUTHOR,
AN OLD COLLEGE FRIEND DINESH
DESOUSA WHO WAS PARDONED TODAY
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM IN A
CONVICTION STEMMING FROM A
BUNDLED CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
OBAMA IS A U.S. ATTORNEY WENT
FOR BROKE AGAINST DESOUSA IN A
CASE THAT COULD HAVE EASILY BEEN
DISPOSED OF WITH A FINE, AND
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
THIS IS DESOUSA WHO I SPOKE WITH
EXCLUSIVELY.
>> WITH REGARD TO BARRERA, I SEE
HIM AS WELL AS ERIC HOLDER AS
PART OF THIS OBAMA TEAM OF GOONS
IF YOU WILL THAT WAS UNLEASHED
TO GET ME IN RETALIATION FOR THE
MOVIE I MADE ABOUT OBAMA.
AND I THINK FOR VERIZON GOAL
WAS, BY GETTING A FELLOW INDIAN,
HE WOULD ENDEAR HIMSELF TO THE
OBAMA TEAM.
THIS WOULD BE FILED UNDER THE
KARMA IS A LEAP DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: HE WAS SENTENCED TO
EIGHT MONTHS AT A COMMUNITY
CONFINEMENT CENTER, PROBATION
AND COMMUNITY SERVICE, A $30,000
FINE, AND COUNSELING.
HE CALLS IT A FAILED ATTEMPT AT
REEDUCATION.
WHEN REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO SUSPECTED POLITICAL
MOTIVATION PUSH FOR THE RELEASE
OF HIS FBI FILE, THE DEPARTMENT
BALKED.
WHEN THEY FINALLY TURNED OVER
THE FILE WERE MADE ACCESS TO THE
FILE, THEY FOUND OUT THAT HIS
POLITICAL AFFILIATION AND WORK
CRITICAL OF OBAMA HAD INDEED
BEEN REFERENCED.
FROM THE FBI REPORT SEEN BY
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
IT SAID THE FOLLOWING.
DESOUSA IS LIKELY AN ULTRA
CONSERVATIVE RIGHT WING AUTHOR
AND CREATOR OF A DOCUMENTARY
CRITICAL OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION COME BECAUSE OF
HIS PURPORTED CONSERVATIVE
DELAYS, IT'S LIKELY THAT HE
ORCHESTRATED THE EXCESS
CONTRIBUTION.
THE PERSON'S NAME WHO WROTE THE
ABOVE DESCRIPTION WAS REDACTED.
THE EXPENDITURE THEN AUTHORIZE
FOR A CASE CONCERNING $20,000
WORTH OF CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS,
$100,000.
>> MY CASE SHOWN IN MINIATURE IS
THE WAY THAT OBAMA AND HILLARY,
TOO, I HAVE GANGSTER EYES IN
U.S. POLITICS.
THERE'S A NEW TERM THAT'S COMING
TO AMERICAN POLITICS AND A
TRUMPET IS I THINK VERY WELL
AWARE OF IT AND IN SOME WAYS A
PRODUCT OF IT.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED TO
VIRGINIA'S REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
BOB McDONALD?
HE WAS PROSECUTED ON CORRUPTION
CHARGES BY U.S. ATTORNEY DANA
VENT HEY WHO WAS APPOINTED.
AND HE WAS ALSO COLLEAGUES WITH
JIM COMEY AND WAS INTERVIEWED BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL BOB MUELLER
ON WHAT COMING RELATED TO HIM
ABOUT HIS MEETING WITH TRUMP.
AND THEN THERE IS A FORMER
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR FROM
ILLINOIS ROB BLAGOJEVICH WHO WAS
SENTENCED TO 14 YEARS IN PRISON,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT HE TOOK A
BRIBE.
ANOTHER JIM COMEY FRIEND,
PATRICK FITZGERALD.
HIS WIFE PATTY RECENTLY APPEARED
HERE ON THE ANGLE.
>> TEN YEARS AGO, THE SAME
PEOPLE TOLD ME THAT GERALD
MUELLER USE THESE OUT-OF-CONTROL
PROSECUTORS AND FBI AGENTS THAT
CAME AFTER MY HUSBAND WITH THEIR
UNCHECKED POWER TO UNDO AN
ELECTION BY THE PEOPLE.
THESE ARE POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
OPPORTUNISTS WHO USE THEIR
OFFICES FOR THEIR OWN PERSONAL
ENRICHMENT TO FURTHER THEIR
CAREERS.
>> REMEMBERED THE DECISION TO
INVESTIGATE THE LEAKING OF CIA
AGENT VALERIE PLANE IN 2003?
SCOOTER LIBBY WAS CONVICTED IN
THAT CASE, NOT FOR LEAKING BUT
FOR LYING TO INVESTIGATORS.
TRUMP RECENTLY PARDON HIM,
SOMETHING GEORGE W. BUSH SHOULD
HAVE DONE LONG BEFORE LEAVING
OFFICE.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHO DECIDED TO
APPOINT SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THAT
CASE?
THEN DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL JIM
COMEY.
WHOM DID CALL ME CHOOSE A
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
HIS OLD CHUM, PATRICK FITZGERALD
HIS OLD CHUM, PATRICK FITZGERAL
FITZGERALD.
IT'S ALL SO INCESTUOUS.
NOW HE IS A PARTNER AT MY OLD
LAW FIRM AND HE'S REPRESENTING
WHOM?
JIM COMEY AND HIS DEALINGS WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL, BOB MUELLER.
THAT BRINGS US TO TODAY WHERE
MANY OF THE SAME FIGURES WHO
HAVE BEEN CELEBRATED BY MEDIA
ELITES ARE BACK AT WORK USING
THEIR POSITION AND THEIR
PEDIGREE, AND AN ONGOING EFFORT
TO PURGE THE COUNTRY OF
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP.
WHAT STARTED AS CONCERNS ABOUT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HAS NOW
MORPHED INTO AN EVER-CHANGING
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
NARRATIVE.
ALL BECAUSE TRUMP FIRED SOMEONE
WHO HE WAS CONSTITUTIONALLY
PERMITTED TO FIRE FOR ANY REASON
PERMITTED TO FIRE FOR ANY REASO
REASON.
IN FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS LIMITLESS
BUDGETS, SUBPOENA POWER AND AN
ARMY OF PROSECUTORS.
SO TARGETS SHOULD NOT BE CHOSEN
OR ELIMINATED ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR POLITICAL VIEWS, NOR
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONSIDERED BIG
FISH WHOSE PROSECUTION COULD PAY
BIG TIME AND A BIG DIVIDENDS
DOWN THE ROAD.
THIS IS NEITHER JUST NOR
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.